today on the matt welsh show now that
the anti-groomer bill has been passed in
florida despite the pro-grooming efforts
of disney republicans in the state have
moved on to punishing and exacting
revenge on disney some milquetoast
conservatives are uncomfortable with
this but i think it's great also jen
pasake tearfully defends the castration
mutilation of children piers morgan
deceptively edits an interview with
donald trump a public health expert
recommends that you bring extra masks
with you in public to hand out to
strangers in our daily cancellation a
woman is concerned because her boyfriend
has dedicated his life to digging a huge
hole in the ground we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt wells
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i don't know what it is about
the left but they straight up hate when
you eat meat when the supply chain and
inflation cause meat prices to soar
their response isn't to solve the supply
chain inflation is to tell you that this
is the perfect opportunity to switch
from juicy delicious nutritious meat
to something called lentils or worse
bugs because you know bugs don't count
apparently apparently their lives don't
count so we just eat them that doesn't
make any sense people like bill gates
and outlets like time magazine tell us
eating bugs is a solution to all of our
problems i've realized something it's
it's not enough to not eat bugs you have
to be anti-bug eating and i say this as
someone who has eaten the bugs before
and uh i do not recommend it that
requires taking action against the bug
eating movement the best way to do that
is to eat more meat so i've decided to
double down on my meat intake and i'm
inviting you to join i just subscribed
to the cowboy box from good ranchers
which contains almost 10 pounds of
all-american beef if you're worried
about the supply chain or inflation
increasing the price of meat over time
the solution is not lentils or crickets
the answer is subscribing to good
ranchers they lock in your price for
life once you subscribe and they only
source from american farm so please
don't let the vegans and bug eaters win
we need to double down on eating meat
literally go to goodranchers.com and
enter promo code walsh check out for 30
off your first order that's good that's
code codewalsh at goodranchers.com for
30 off your first order
you know the left in this country for
many decades were in a rather enviable
position they were playing against a
team that only ever stayed on the
defensive side of the ball
you know the right only ever played
defense sometimes it played defense
relatively well most of the time it
played defense poorly sometimes it
didn't play defense at all but the one
enduring fact through quarter after
quarter of this never-ending football
game is that the right never had
possession of the ball they were never
advancing up the field it was all
defense all the time
the problem is that it doesn't matter
how well you played defense you could
have a hall of fame defense you could
have lawrence taylor and ray lewis in
their primes on your defense and you
still won't win if you never move the
line of scrimmage in the other direction
toward the other goal line
now that may be changing finally or at
least there's a push on the right to
change that
the most important political fight right
now is not between republicans and
democrats but between the new right and
the old right between the faction that
wants to take the ball away from the
left and run up field the other way and
the old sort of tired milk toast
establishment faction that wants to keep
doing things as they've always been done
no matter how fruitless and unproductive
those methods were and still are
now this rift between new and old right
has really come to the foreground in
recent days with um well really in
recent months it has but especially in
recent days with this news out of
florida as the daily wire reports
florida's republican-led senate passed a
bill on wednesday that eliminates a
special taxing district that allows walt
disney company to govern the land where
its theme park is located the measure
potentially delivers a blow to the
company's operations in the state the
wall street journal reported the special
district created in 1967 and known as
the reedy creek improvement district
exempts disney from a host of
regulations and certain taxes and fees
related to emergency services and road
maintenance
the report noted the special taxing
district reportedly saves disney tens of
millions of dollars per year the bill
now has the florida's republican-led
house where it's expected to pass
florida governor ron desantis has
already signaled that he will sign the
bill into law
now thanks to this policy which was put
in place back in 1960s disney has been
its own little fiefdom its own literally
its own kingdom
in the middle of florida it essentially
governs itself and along with those
privileges of autonomy came enormous tax
benefits and breaks
so desantis and his republican
counterparts in florida
want to take that sweet little deal
which has profited disney to the tune of
billions and just toss it into the wood
chipper
why well obviously because disney is not
interested in keeping to itself and
being its own thing it wanted to use its
vast resources to intrude into florida
politics and impact florida legislation
it wanted to craft florida law even
while remaining exempt
largely from florida law
and it wanted to do all this in defense
of child groomers it came out fully in
favor of and committed to the sexual
indoctrination of children
it proved itself to be an enemy of
florida parents and parents across the
country and the world
why should it retain its special
privileges in light of that why
shouldn't it be punished for what it's
what it's done
why shouldn't it be made to feel the
pain
defense is simply stopping disney's
intrusion it's just saying no you can't
do that
offense is punching back and punching
back hard
and making sure that they feel it
offense is making an example of them
offense is taking mickey mouse's head
and putting it on a spike
metaphorically of course
and offense is what we need
one of the great things about turning
the tables and playing offense like this
is that it exposes the utter vapidity
and hollowness of your enemies who who
usually spend their time of course
crying about evil billionaires and
corporations but are now suddenly crying
on behalf of evil billionaires and
corporations
one of the effects of this move in
florida is is to essentially raise taxes
on disney right and since when has the
left ever been opposed to raising taxes
on a billion dollar mega corporation
well since right now this moment because
they are a bunch of dishonest hacks
speaking of which here's simone sanders
who once worked for bernie sanders and
is now on cable news
bragging
about the big and tough and cool
disney lobbyists let's listen
i i know
fashion corporations is popular left and
right these days i'd be careful going oh
my money is on the disney lobbyist would
you would you like my money on the
disney lobbyist do you think those those
state legislators down in florida are
going to bend to the will of the
governor did you see what jared polis
said he'd love a rocky mountain disney
yeah
but by the way the florida legislature
the state senate just passed this bill
to strip disney of its special accident
so from eat the rich
to yay go disney lobbyists
a slight rebranding there you might say
if these people had any credibility to
begin with it would be burned to ash
right now
yet some voices on the right are taking
up
this cause alongside these leftist
hypocrites defending disney
for example writing for the national
review charles c w cook calls the move
to take away disney's privileges
grotesque and ugly
he says there's no need to
for republicans to punish disney or
quote take revenge or quote salt the
earth we shouldn't be doing that
he says
well on the contrary charles that is
exactly what we need to do
meanwhile conservative radio host eric
erickson tweeted uh quote kind of at the
point of thinking this is where the
right begins to overplay its hand on the
woke stuff where gop takes away the
disney tax district
the left had been the bullies the right
one
they risk looking like sore winners
the voters hate bullies more than
policies
i once again disagree you're right the
left had been the bullies
it's time for the right to be the
bullies
rather than complaining oh you're being
a bully
now see you you want the other side you
actually want the other side to accuse
you of that
you want to be you want to put them in a
position where they're saying you're
bullying us
because that
is a losing proposition
that's a lose literally a loser's
talking point
when you're when you're stooping to
having to accuse the other side of being
bullies
that means you're losing
writing for a conservative blog hot air
ala pundit agrees saying
no one believes that disney would be
facing this reckoning if it had
cheerlead the don't say gay bill which
means the action florida is taking
although facially neutral is textbook
viewpoint discrimination by the
government
now notice how this person on the right
supposedly in a supposed right-wing
publication which has a pop-up on it on
its homepage asking the reader to
support conservative journalism
actually refers to the parental rights
bill as the don't say gay bill he adopts
the absurd farcical far left straw man
talking point about this legislation as
if it's a neutral fact that's a don't
say gay bill
and then he accuses florida of viewpoint
discrimination for taking away a special
privilege that it did not have any legal
right to in the first place
and what viewpoint are we discriminating
against the viewpoint that children
should be sexualized well yeah we should
discriminate against that viewpoint
the right many on the right anyway are
used to losing i think they've grown
accustomed to it they're comfortable
with it they actually prefer it
you know the good thing about being a
loser is you never have to do anything
there are no risks involved there's no
tough calls no hard decisions no need
for a plan
you can't fumble a ball that you never
have the guts to carry in the first
place
some on the right have enjoyed playing
the role of speed bump lying their press
rate you know lumps on the ground
moderately slowing the left's advance
maybe and then waving as the convoy
drives right over them and toward the
horizon
that's an easy role to play it's simple
it's safe as long as you don't mind the
tire marks on your face
not a lot of dignity in it
but who cares about dignity i mean they
certainly don't
some of us do though
some of us also if you can imagine it
actually believe
what we're saying we believe in the
things we're fighting for
when we talk about kids being groomed
and abused and indoctrinated
we believe that we're not just saying it
we believe it
another thing that i think a lot of
people
in the on the establishment the old
right
that's something they can't believe and
don't understand because they're so used
to just sort of saying things whether
they believe them or not
and then they look at us over here and
they say you guys actually believe this
stuff
what
you know if we believe it of course we
want to exact revenge on the people who
are targeting kids
of course we're going to punish them
take vengeance on them
salt the earth with their ashes sounds
good to me
that's what you do when you really care
when you really mean it
when you really understand the stakes
when you actually want to win
and we want to win
if you don't then lie back down
speed bump
and let the rest of us do what needs to
be done
we don't need your help
now we don't want it now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
all right well jenn pasake will be
moving to msnbc in a few months no
conflict of interest there at all i mean
she's the still right now the press
secretary
and she's supposed to field questions
from the media
and they're supposed to be
an antagonistic relationship
between
the the press secretary the white house
and the media because they're supposed
to be holding you accountable
democracy dies in darkness right
washington post um
but james hockey now is in the position
of uh she's you know doing this press
conferences with people who are she's
they're going to be her co-workers in a
couple of months and and um
so but no not no conflict of interest
there and now she seems to really be
sort of preparing for that gig here she
is crying
crying
over the thought of kids not being
drugged and castrated just to reiterate
that she's crying
over the thought of kids not being
drugged and castrated
idea of you know the very idea
that a 14 year old girl
might not have her breasts chopped off
the very idea that a 12 year old boy
might not be chemically castrated and
sterilized for life
reduces her to tears
watch this
the political
games and harsh and cruel uh attempts at
laws or laws that we're seeing in some
states like florida that is not a
reflection of the country moving to
oppose lgbtq plus communities that is
not what we see in data that is not
factual and that is not where things
stand this is a political wedge issue
and an attempt to win a culture war and
they're doing that in a way that is
harsh and cruel uh to a community of
kids especially i'm i'm like going to
get them i'm going to get emotional
about this issue because it's just it's
horrible
but uh but you know it's it's like kids
who are bullied and
this is like all these leaders are
taking steps to hurt them and hurt their
lives and hurt their families and you
look at some of these laws in these
states and it is going after parents who
are in loving relationships who have
kids it's completely outrageous um but
it is it is a wedge issue sorry i and
this is an issue that makes me
completely crazy um but it is an issue
that um is a political wedge issue it is
not a reflection of where the country is
uh
you see this is this is what we're up
against why
just playing defense is is not an option
when this is what you're dealing with
actually reduced to tears it's it's not
just that she's
arguing for and trying to justify the
chemical castration and and mutilation
and butchering of kids
which of course will be bad enough
but that she's
emotional about the idea that we would
protect kids from that
just think about it and she's yeah
there's there's some acting involved in
the crying but it's not all acting
i think we make a mistake to just assume
that that's all performance that might
be a part of it
but then you're i think you're you're
kind of doing her some favors in a way
because no she really is these people
really are that deranged
to not only be in favor of chopping the
breasts off of 14 year old girls but to
be
emotional about it
she says we have to protect kids from
bullying well
i agree with
that and there are no greater bullies
right now
who are targeting kids
than the
vultures in the pharmaceutical industry
and the medical industry
who are taking advantage of these kids
and who have
who are responsible for whatever like a
4 000 increase in gender dysphoria among
kids
who are inculcating
this this
identity crisis and then profiting off
of it
making kids confused about who they are
so that they can
mutilate them and profit off it monetize
it
so those are the bullies
and when there are laws put in place to
protect kids those are not laws against
the kids
those are laws against what the adults
are doing to those kids
um
there's no there's no compromising with
people like this
you know
there's no just like stopping their
advance and then saying okay well let's
just
stay right here don't don't just stop
stop right there don't don't try to go
any farther
we can reach an understanding
no these people have to be destroyed
and humiliated
and shamed
okay that's what they need
there's there's no other option
what other option is there for someone
who would be in tears
tearfully defending the mutilation of
kids
staying on this note here um nicole
nicole wallace on msnbc
is so upset about the parental rights
bills that we've seen in florida and
other places that she actually compared
the parental rights bills
giving parents
rights over their own children
and stopping government employees from
talking to six-year-olds about
about sex she compared that to child
rape
and war crimes
listen
and i worry that in covering glenn
juncken and his politics of parental
choice all the focus was on how well it
worked and even in our conversations
about desantis it's about how well
they're serving him the the truth is
dehumanization
as a tactic for politics is from war
dehumanization is a it's a it's a tactic
it's being used right now
the russians get their soldiers
to rape children by dehumanizing them
dehumanization as a practice is a tactic
of war it's being deployed in our
politics and people like you and i
sometimes lose the plot and admire its
effectiveness not acceptance but even
the analysis of these tactics loses
sight of what of what this speech brings
us back to which is that dehumanization
has a cost right now
right now as it's being deployed there
are children and and chats and bitter
judges made this point when don't ask
don't tell was introduced kids will die
kids kids will die kids will die if we
don't groom indoctrinate
abuse and sexualize them that's what
she's saying
because
and i think we should be very clear
about what all this is
the sexual indoctrination of children
the um
foisting the
gender dysphoria onto them
um this the transitioning quote-unquote
of children all of this
is sexual abuse
quote unquote transitioning a child
trying to turn a little boy into a
little girl that's that is psychological
abuse it's physical abuse it is also at
the deepest sense sexual abuse
and so what she is saying what this
freak what this monster this lunatic
this psychopath
this goblin is saying
is that kids will die if we don't
sexually abuse them
and she is comparing not sexual sexually
abusing kids
to raping them like how do you even make
sense of that
but that's what we're getting from these
ghouls
and if it couldn't if you didn't think
it could get any worse it does well
here's here's one fact that makes it a
worse rate and i think this ties back to
what we talked about in the opening with
the you know the old right and the
establishment republican thing
um nicole wallace just so you know she
she used to work in the bush white house
she worked in the bush white house and
she worked for john mccain
so she's a republican historically
and this is where she is now
so what does that tell you about the
republican party
uh and then a little bit later in this
conversation tim miller
who also used to be a republican former
rnc spokesman
um here is his his response now remember
nicole wallace is saying that there's
that their side is being dehumanized or
whatever and um here is tim miller's
response to that listen
um with what mallory was saying right
carville i think said on this network
yesterday uh republicans are weird and
like we need to call them weird right
and so i think there has to be a
humanizing of your side but plus going
on offense a little bit on the other
side right and if part of the reason why
glenn young was elected was because
parents were uncomfortable with what
some of the school board judgments are
doing do you want the people that charge
the capital deciding what the math books
are going to be that's not popular right
like these weirdos that are talking
about mickey and pluto making love and
all this sort of weird stuff they're
talking about and all the sort of
extreme stuff they're talking about
nobody wants them deciding what's in the
math books either right so i think that
there is a way to to push down and and
to to limit the strength of their
argument by by pointing out just how how
odd and how extreme it is and then by
humanizing yourself as well and by
pointing out the families that are going
to suffer from this like anybody who has
a kindergartener
five-year-old cook i've got a
four-year-old she's always asking uh you
know what tommy has one dad like tommy's
grandma picked what's the deal with that
family anyone who has a kindergartner
knows you can't ban discussion of
different families from a kindergarten
classroom
oh they're weird they're so weird as his
answer now what he really wanted to say
he kind of stopped himself
uh what because he said yeah we have to
humanize our side and then
and then go on offense what he actually
meant to say is what he was trying to
say what he was clearly saying is we
want to humanize our side and dehumanize
the other side that's what he was really
saying there pretty clearly
and that was in
response to nicole wallace's whole whole
speech about how the republicans are
dehumanizing people tim miller responds
by saying we need to dehumanize them and
she's laughing and nodding along well of
course we're going to dehumanize them i
mean obviously
no we they're not people they're not
humans so we can dehumanize them
remember what i said yesterday that any
time they make a statement about uh you
know especially if they're decrying the
way that people are treated there's
always the asterisks there's always
you know there's always that uh
clause at the end
which is it's wrong to dehumanize people
unless they deserve it
it's wrong to be intolerant and hateful
unless they deserve it
it's wrong it would take away their
human rights unless they deserve it
so you see that yet again but he says
that um well republicans are weird
they're weird for this
okay give me some examples
and by the way i'm fine tim miller
um you pervert freak i am fine
with having the conversation on these
this this ground here so what you want
right you you want to
throw
accusations back and forth have a
contest over who's more of a weirdo
perfectly fine
because prior to this the response
usually was like if we accused you of
being weird and bizarre um then what
we'd hear from the other side is well
you shouldn't call people weird and
bizarre and that's a bad thing to do you
know we should be accepting of people so
it seems like you're tossing that out
now and you're saying no that's a
legitimate charge to make against
somebody
and now it's just a contest to figure
out who the weird ones are
and i'm really excited to have that
conversation we can have that
conversation
tim so
but give me some examples because you
didn't you go out you see he goes on for
a minute about there are the weird ones
and he doesn't give any examples of the
weird he says oh these are the people
who charge the capital actually they're
not uh glenn younkin didn't charge
capital rhonda sanders is in charge of
capital
there's a tiny sliver of a minority
a relative handful of people in
comparison with everyone on the right
the millions of people who did that
and so if you want to call them weird
for doing that then go ahead
but
we you know
we i didn't charge the capital any more
than you tim miller
invaded a police station
in minneapolis when blm did and burned
it to the ground i assume you didn't do
that so i'm not gonna say that you did
so that's not gonna work and then okay
so what's the weird thing
talking about mickey and pluto having
sex no that's that's see we're saying we
don't want to talk about that but what
we're saying is we don't want sexual
content in children's entertainment and
we don't want our kids in school to be
sexualized that's what we do not want
you do want it
so you're taking the position
that a little boy
that a little four-year-old boy can
actually be a girl
that if a little four-year-old boy who
has no concept of reality whatsoever
says i'm a girl not understanding what
that statement even means
that we should actually put him in a
dress and raise him as a girl
and put him on a path to when he's 12
years old get sterilizing him
with drugs that we give to sex offenders
to chemically castrate them and then a
little bit later after that um you know
uh chopping his his penis into pieces
and trying to turn it into a vagina
that's what you support so you want to
have a weirdo conversation that's the
weird stuff
and i can use a lot of words stronger
than that that you support
i'd like to give the examples of what
the what's the weird thing
oh yeah we're such weirdos we we think
that
that um
men are male women are females
um you shouldn't talk to little
five-year-olds about transgenderism or
encourage them to cross-dress like that
that's that's that's our whole position
on this issue
a bunch of weirdos we are
sure
um
speaking of weirdos camila harris
yesterday i don't know why they keep
putting her in these positions i'm i'm
speaking some of rhetorically when i say
i don't know why but um i mean i do know
why is it that nobody in the white house
or in their democrat party likes her
because they could before we play this
clip
and this is not the worst camille harris
clip but then the bar is very low so it
doesn't quite get down this is not um
when she was when she was pontificating
about the passage of time and it's not
quite there but it's it's almost there
but what you have to keep in mind when
you listen to this clip
is that she's giving a speech
and we have to assume that she's given
prepared remarks
by people who are aware of her
reputation
for saying inane ridiculous
meaningless things and so
they they could give her things to say
that are not that
and yet
this is what we get listen
space is exciting
it spurs our imaginations
and it forces us
to ask
big questions
space
it affects us
all and it connects
us all
yeah those are those are definitely okay
yeah she's got the
teleprompters there those are prepared
remarks
space affects us all and it connects it
assault does it though
i mean this once again
as always with her it sounds like
she was just
thrown up to the front of the class to
give a presentation on outer space and
had not prepared for it at all and so
this is what space
is really interesting
space is space
space is big
space
is
dark
but there are things in space
which is very big
and it connects us all
does it connect us all in what way does
space connect us
what way does space
what way does it affect well i guess in
a certain way i mean we're all on planet
earth which is in
space
uh orbiting around the sun so in that
way i mean if you didn't have
if you didn't have space then then
there'd just be nothing but space kind
of is not i don't know
it's kind of mind-boggling it's your
mind boggles after a while um trying to
make sense of this
it probably would have been better just
to give her something else to say
but they are setting her up for failure
every step of the way
speaking of
a lot of great transitions here speaking
of getting set up for failure donald
trump uh sat down for an interview with
piers morgan apparently sometime in the
last couple of days and i say sometimes
it lasts a couple days because uh trump
sat down for a pre-recorded interview
with piers morgan
and here's how that interview was
advertised watch
it appears i'm ready a former president
in denial i'll be
i think i'm a very honest man much more
honest than you actually really yeah it
was a free and fair launch you lost only
a four would think do you think i'm
available i do now yeah excuse me okay
excuse me the most explosive interview
of the year i don't think you're real
i'm not like very different let's finish
up the interview morgan versus the
camera
okay so they have him appearing to storm
off turn the camera off
um but then we get this from breitbart
it says audio provided by former
president donald trump uh and his team
to breitbart news at the end of trump's
interview
with pierce morgan proves that morgan
and his team deceptively edited the
interview to make it appear as though it
was a contentious ending when it was not
it says a 30-second promotional clip
that morgan released on wednesday
afternoon seemed to show trump flying
off the handle and walking out
mid-interview as a righteous morgan
asked him tough questions about his
views on 20 election
um but it turns out and and there's a
audio that he provided the full audio
and
i mean you can hear in the audio um
he just the interview's over and trump
gets up and and because the interview is
over he says uh you can you can turn the
cameras off now
and then peers says to him that was a
great interview so it's a very friendly
kind of ending
and they cut it together to make it seem
like
he's stormed out um so just deceptive
dishonest uh that they're using and
piers morgan i think he just started
this new show after getting cancelled on
the
um
uh on a different show and now he's got
a new show and he's and and donald trump
was was very nice
to sit down for a pre-recorded interview
to help pierce morgan's ratings
and that's what brings me to what i have
to say about this
and the right today has been
you know defending trump and they've
been saying oh trump was treated
unfairly by the media um which is so in
other words it's like what for for four
years of trump in the white house
it's like what what the right was
focused on almost
solely
was defending trump against unfair media
so what i'm going to say about this and
i know that some of you my sweet babies
think that i'm too hard on trump
so you're not going to like
what i have to say here
and you also have to understand that i
don't think it's possible to be too hard
on a politician especially a guy who was
president
because it's just it's not it's not
possible to be too harsh i don't think
i blame trump for this 100 percent
and i think it shows
some of the major problems we would have
in 2024 if he's the guy
i blame him because
why in the hell
why in god's name take your pick
would you as a man who has been in media
and and in politics
and who knows how the game is played why
would you make the decision to sit down
for a pre-recorded interview
with piers morgan
why would you sit for a pre-recorded
interview with a corporate media hack
why
i know what he been he benefits from it
because it helps his ratings but
so that's what you're doing you're
trying to help the media with their
ratings
be a nice guy
tell me why
now i've been around for a much shorter
time than trump and i have much less
experience i would never in a million
years do a pre-recorded interview with
someone who i cannot 100
absolutely and totally trust
and the number of people that i can
absolutely totally trust in this way is
like that number is
almost non-existent
like i would sit down for a pre-recorded
interview
with somebody here at the daily wire
and
that's almost
that's pretty much it that's that might
be the entire list
and i certainly wouldn't go into someone
who who disagrees with me politically
and do a pre-record in it because then
they can do exactly this they can edit
it however they want
yet trump decided to do that he stood to
gain nothing what do you gain from it
nothing
yet he did it
um
and it's the same old story over and
over again i'm just so sick of it like
trump puts himself in these positions
for no reason just because like he can't
someone offers him a camera and they
flatter him a little bit and say well
you'd be a great interview and you'd
help our ratings and he just he can't
say no to that
but you need to be able to say no to
that
and he doesn't have anyone in his circle
he hasn't surrounded himself with
anybody who will tell them the truth and
if there is anyone to tell the truth
they get fired
so there's nobody in a circle who would
say no uh mr president you cannot do
this
you want to sit down live with piers
morgan maybe but even then why
why him what do you gain from that
you're the most famous guy in the world
you could do an interview with anybody
why piers morgan what does he give you
and he decides to do it and then
and then the inevitable happens
and then we have a whole new cycle where
the right is focused on defending trump
and this is like i said for four years
this is what it was the every day it was
the trumps being unfairly attacked by
the media again and meanwhile what's the
left focused on they're focused on
further you know uh furthering their
agenda in education
you know getting more getting more
gender ideology more crt into the
classroom
they're focused on that you know it's
it's actually not a coincidence
that
it was it wasn't until really the end of
trump's term and when he was gone
that the right really honed in on these
issues in education gender ideology
especially like we re the the um school
board
movement
actually paying attention to what's
happening locally that didn't happen
until trump was gone and the reason for
that
is it's not it's not that trump tried to
prevent us from focusing on this it
wasn't well it wasn't his intention it's
just that when he's around it's just for
the right all they do is talk about him
and defend him that's it
while everything else is happening in
the world that really matters
this is a perfect example of it
and i'm sorry i'm just not everyone else
on the right today can say oh trump's up
fairly
sorry that's your fault don't do that i
would say this to anybody i would say
this to anybody on the right you sat
down for a pre-recorded interview with
somebody you can't trust that's on you
like what are you doing
and now i got to defend you because you
made that dumb decision
for the 50th time
come on
and the other thing you see in that by
the way
is that
um first of all the media they they want
trump to run they desperately want this
guy to run they love him
they that's the dirty little secret that
should not be a secret to anyone they
love him and they want him there it's
why they talk about him so much he's
great for their ratings and he knows
they're great that he's great for their
ratings and he likes that he's great for
their ratings and that's one of the
reasons he does all these interviews
even though he stands to gain nothing
from them
um
so they want to run the other thing that
they want is they want to talk about
2020.
what here's what would be the best case
scenario for them for dems in 2024 it is
that trump runs and that the entire 2024
election cycle is a rehash and a
relitigation of 2020. that's what they
want
because what they absolutely do not want
is to talk about biden and his failures
and how he destroyed the country for
four years for four years and what they
don't want to talk about is called are
these cultural issues obviously gender
ideology crt the school system they
don't talk about any of that
they can't talk about it they can't
defend it
they don't know how to talk about it
they still haven't figured it out
they want to talk about trump and they
want to talk about 2020
and they want to talk about trump's
tenure and they want to that's what they
want to make it about they want to make
the 2024 election about
2016 through 2020
and just erase
2020 through 2024 that's what they want
to do
we cannot let that happen
all right
um
one other thing from emma's we played
way too much msnbc recently
unfortunately but uh i got to play just
one more thing here's a talking head
doctor
on msnbc giving some masking advice
listen to this
if people want to stay safe the best
thing they can do high quality mass and
that when possible carry some extra
masks i know this sounds crazy but if
you tell someone next to you on a plane
pay a 95 and just say or surgical mask
and just say i've got an elderly mother
at home i've got a child with cancer at
home will you please do me a favor
having the people at least closest to
you in that row protecting yourself and
them
can be the best safety so carry some
extra masks with you carry some rapid
tests with you if you're traveling
it carries some tests it's about she
didn't say are you giving them the test
too when you sit down uh sorry i don't
mean to bug you but could you just take
this uh this uh this well first i have a
health question eric can you just uh
just check yes or no on this box it's
only 50 questions and then um i'm gonna
do a little bit of blood work here's a
rapid test and here's three masks would
you mind just putting those on for me i
i don't mean to impose i don't mean to
impose
lord dear lord in heaven please let
someone try this with me please please
try i am begging you
send someone to me next to me on a plane
to try to hand me a mask and ask me to
put it on
um
i i would love that i would love the
opportunity to respond to that
query
and my response will be along the lines
of hell no but maybe a little bit more
colorful i'll probably have a little bit
more to say than that but that's gonna
be that's gonna be the thrust of it
really is what it's gonna be
um
but of course the left they're just they
can't get over this masking thing uh
some of them anyway
here's jerome adams he's uh now calls
himself a health equity director he used
to be a certain general under trump and
um he posted this today says flying
today a delta
pilot walked by me in the airport and
said take your mask off man breathe free
gotta love that pilot
and he's uh why is it those who so
strongly felt others were imposing their
beliefs
in health wellness and compassion on
them feel so free to impose their belief
on others
well in what way is he imposing his
belief on you by just saying hey take
your mask off breathe free
he's concerned about your mental
well-being
he's concerned about you
and then dr emily ricotta who's a
epidemiologist she tweeted this in
defiance of the mask mandate removal
i'm double masked and bringing some sass
to the airport this morning and she's
got her double masks on and then she's
got a shirt that says trust me on it
trust me i'm an epidemiologist
well i'm glad to know you're an
epidemiologist but trust i think we go
the other direction that that that's the
red flag that signals to me that i
cannot trust you based on the last two
years of experience
um how are you in defiance of the
removal of a mandate
nobody is saying that
you can't wear the mask
now
i think that we should say that actually
talk about going on offense the theme
here
um i would say it's actually not enough
to just get rid of the mask mandates and
move on
we now need there to be
laws put in place
ensuring that no mask mandates can ever
be passed again especially in schools
every state in the in the country should
be
passing laws every every red state
anywhere
every alleged red state should be
passing laws saying you cannot
mask mandates in school are illegal
and i would even go
because i am such a bully i would go
farther than that and i would also pass
laws banning masking itself i would say
you cannot wear a mask in public unless
you need to get a uh
unless you have a specific
health-related need
so if you if you can obtain a health
exemption
let's say you are going through
chemotherapy something like that then
you get a health exemption and you can
wear a mask but everybody else you can
why can't you um
because it because you look stupid
that's why
if i was governor that'd be my whole
reason it just looks stupid and so i'm
saying you can't do it
that's all if i have to give a better
reason there are better reasons one is
that it's a it's a it's a public safety
risk
it is legitimately a public safety risk
to have people walking around the masks
having masses of people walking around
with anonymity we've seen what happens
over the last two years we've all seen
it the mass looting the crime wave all
of that is directly connected to the
masking that's why when you watch all
these videos of the looting sprees and
everything else whether it was during
blm riots or just these things that
happen on their own now in san francisco
los angeles and other places
they're almost always wearing masks
and that was something that some of us
including yours truly predicted early on
and was laughed at for saying
well you have everybody wearing masks
now we're going to have shoplifting and
everything left and right
and people scoffed at that so what
what's the connection there
so public safety hazard that's why that
is if i had to come up with a better
reason then it looks stupid uh my real
reason would be it's a public safety
hazard people walking around masks and
what's more it's also psychological
health
we care about mental health these days
don't we it is bad for mental health to
walk around in a mask
and it's bad for other people's mental
health to have to see you it is bad it
it is harmful to my mental health
when i have to walk around seeing
people in masks
so those are my reasons
let's get down to the comment section
[Music]
jack walsh no relation as far as an o
says a mascot is representation of your
group of people whether it's your school
or your team or whatever
these kids are proud to be represented
by native american symbols and heritage
look at the reverence they're giving
their performance why is this offensive
in the least well that's exactly the
point with all these
alleged offensive mascots indian mascots
um
people are proud of the mascots that's
why that's why fan bases have tried to
hold on to them
because they
are proud of the mascots
and when you
make something into a mascot
you make a person into a mascot that is
you
that is uh reverence that is you paying
homage that's you know
that's that's a sign of respect
as i said yesterday you don't you don't
make a mascot out of something or
someone that you think is pathetic
inferior weak whatever
um boyer says till we have faces is the
secret gem of c.s lewis's works i read
it every couple of years or so and every
time uh walk away with something
different
yeah i kind of
fluctuate between which c.s lewis work
is my my favorite and um
but i do think ultimately and i've
always gravitated towards this purely
apologetic
works i mean
uh everything he did is
is apologetic in a certain way till we
have faces certainly is but it's also
it's a novel it's a fictional story
um there's a lot of allegorical elements
to it i've always i've always i've
always gravitated towards things like
you know the problem of pain um
mere christianity stuff like that
that's very clearly straightforward
apologetics but recently especially i've
i've um
found myself connecting with talia faces
so right now i would say i think that's
the best c.s lewis book
um tyler says hey matt former infantry
here and i can honestly say people that
go overseas into combat zones
politicians photographers etc with
little to no experience slash trading
are extremely valuable not because
they're good at what they do but because
they keep our morale high
by keeping us laughing
at their expense of course okay so
that's the one advantage i was asking
yesterday guys like malcolm
nance these uh cable news pundits who
are now going to ukraine
and larping as uh as you know ukrainian
warriors
is the people on the ground there who
are actually fighting
are they are they happy to see the cable
news pundits show up someone who's out
of shape at 60 years old is that like
are they
were they hoping that somebody like that
would come and help
and this is the answer apparently a
little bit of uh
i guess you could use that being in that
environment high stress environment
obviously
uh having a little bit of a
little bit of comedic
break i think is good
uh aiden says matt i've been crying all
day since i heard this heartbreaking
news pooh sheisty has been sentenced to
five and a half years in prison
i'm barely able to even type this
message due to all the tears on my
screen hope you're holding up okay
yeah you know i saw this yesterday i
wanted to talk about it but it was too
painful
it was too much i needed time to process
it and pray about it and um i still
don't know what to say
my man poo sheisty is going to prison
for five and a half years and that means
five and a half years without
his music i mean yeah we have his his
classics right we have what he has
contributed so far to humanity he's
going to contribute so much more
but
not having new push ice to music
it's kind of unbearable for me
why is he going to prison well because
of racism
and because of anti-poo bias in the
justice system which is a problem that
is not discussed nearly enough
um they jammed pooh up on some phony
charges
and now he an innocent poo is going to
prison it's unconscionable
but here's the good news
if i knew if i know push isd and i do
he's going to endure this hardship
with great courage and dignity i mean
this is push ice that we're talking
about
a man whose spirit will not be broken
easily so that's the good message
um
may we all be a little bit more like poo
sheisty
and like his friend spot him got him
who actually it just so happens was shot
recently but i think he's okay as far as
i know thank god
one tragedy at a time
so prayers for poo
godspeed my friend come back to us soon
you know if there's one question i never
thought i'd seriously be asking the
general public it's what is a woman but
here we are and not only am i asking the
question i've made an entire film and
written an entire book trying to answer
it both are called what is a woman and
the book is now available for pre-order
what is a woman.com also on amazon or
was number one on the best seller charts
in the women's studies category before
of course being removed from the list so
help me find the answer to this elusive
question pre-order my book what is a
woman at what is a woman.com or on
amazon and go to what is woman.com also
to see the trailer for the film which
will be coming out very soon uh very
excited about that as well now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know one of my favorite pieces of
extra content that we post on our
youtube channel are my reddit
relationship advice videos and this is
when i comb through the relationship
forums on reddit to impart my wisdom to
the confused and helpless souls who are
so desperate that they're actually
stooping to soliciting advice from the
reddit community now my advice may not
be great from an objective standpoint
but it's better than anything that you
know they'll get from reddit so
today in that spirit i'll be trying to
help a young woman whose relationship
quandary has posted to reddit went viral
this week um i'll be helping her and
i'll also be canceling her because
that's what we do in this segment
nothing personal
i mean usually it is pretty personal but
never mind that a woman named kate
whitaker on twitter
seems to be one of the first to have
taken this post and amplified it causing
it to go viral she tweeted the
screenshot along with a caption
revealing her bias she says what on
earth is going on with men
ironically though the man in question is
not on earth he is under the earth where
all men wish to be
the reddit post is titled how can i get
my boyfriend to stop digging his tunnel
now we see the problem already from the
way she framed the situation she says
how can i get him to stop
rather than should i get him to stop
which is the real question you should be
asking she's assuming from the outset
that she should stop her boyfriend from
digging his tunnel to her it's
self-evident that men should not dig
tunnels but to men
it's self-evident that we should and we
must
i'm getting ahead of myself a little bit
here's um her version of the story let's
read it
she says so i know this is a weird
question but my boyfriend likes to spend
a lot of his free time digging a tunnel
on some property that he inherited i
haven't seen the full extent of it but
last i saw it was remarkably deep under
the surface he spent roughly a year on
it and it's evident the front of the
thing is deep wide well put together at
the front which is the only part i've
seen he's got cement beams cement beams
electric lights even chairs and a small
table
i haven't gotten into it i haven't gone
into it but it looked like the quality
severely dropped as the tunnel went
further
mostly becoming open dirt with some wood
beams holding it up
now pausing here for a moment
it is baffling to me that her boyfriend
has been digging this awesome tunnel and
she hasn't even gone into it
this is like if he had spent a year
painting a masterpiece or chiseling a
beautiful sculpture out of rock and you
didn't even bother to look at it what if
you were in the sistine chapel
in the year 1512 and he told you that he
just finished painting the ceiling
and he's like i just finished painting
that whole ceiling it took me forever
and you're just like oh cool and you
didn't even bother to look up and check
it out this is shocking to me
especially when the thing in question is
a badass tunnel
she continues
my biggest concern is his safety i'm
really worried that he's going to dig
too deep and it'll collapse on him or
something i've tried voicing this
concern to him but he just laughs it off
and assures me that he'll be fine
aside from safety concerns there's also
the fact that he doesn't really have a
social life because of this thing
i'm pretty much the only person he still
talks to outside of his job and he
doesn't go out and do anything anymore
it used to be that he'd occasionally
head out and do some digging on the
weekends but now he spends almost all of
his free time out there he still comes
home but he barely spends any time with
me and i know that he isn't going to be
he isn't doing anything but digging that
damn hole in the ground this can't be
good for his mental health but i don't
know how to convince him to stop he's
always really happy when he comes back
from digging which is why i haven't
seriously tried to stop him before but i
was talking to a friend about him and
she told me he might be going crazy
obviously i don't think he's insane but
i hadn't considered the mental health
aspect of this and i just don't know
what to do
okay let's clear a few things up
now yes sure there are some valid safety
concerns here if the tunnel isn't
properly built and supported or
ventilated you could you know
die but let's just put the risk of death
aside for a second that's a minor detail
frankly and also i see no reason for us
to assume given the information provided
but this man is digging his tunnel in an
unsafe way that would be i believe an
erroneous assumption so
let's table the whole dying situation
for a moment
and uh look at the bigger picture
first of all speaking to the woman who
wrote this
your problem fundamentally is that you
think you have to understand everything
about the man you're dating but you
can't and you won't
woman will never fully comprehend man
just as man will never fully comprehend
woman we are made for each other and yet
we are mysteries to each other that's
the essence of romance
the difference though is that man knows
he cannot understand woman and he's okay
with that
woman in fact becomes very frustrated by
just how okay with it he is
so you know she'll say something cryptic
and out of context to him and he'll have
no idea what she's talking about but
he'll just go oh okay
uh okay
and then get back to what he's doing and
she'll stand there stunned and say well
aren't you gonna ask me what i'm talking
about
and he'll say okay yeah what were you
talking about and he'll just hope it
isn't a long story but it always is
on the flip side man can say nothing at
all he can simply walk into the room
with a slightly abnormal facial
expression and woman will start
interrogating and waterboarding him to
extract every last piece of information
she can about this facial expression
what are you thinking she'll ask
and she won't accept it when he says
nothing even if that really is the
answer
she must understand everything about him
but she won't
and she can't accept that
and even though she won't
i will now endeavor to lay out a few
facts about men that may help women
especially this woman
the first is this
every man dreams of two things often
related
having a secret door in his house that
leads to a secret room
and building a great tunnel
this tunnel might connect one secret
room to another or it might simply go
all the way down to the center of the
earth where we hope we'll
expect to find goblins and dinosaurs and
elvis hiding out or whatever
there's something cathartic about
digging
we are called into the earth into the
caverns we hear the siren song just as
our forefathers did assuming our
forefathers were meerkats or dwarves
from middle earth or something
you can't understand this we don't
understand this and yet this is just how
it is
the other thing about men
is that we're prone to becoming randomly
obsessed with very weird and specific
things out of nowhere
again we cannot explain this
we shouldn't have to explain it
for example
i recently decided that i want to get a
giant aquarium with lots of rare and
tropical fish in my house
and i keep telling my wife about it and
she keeps wanting to understand why i'm
obsessed with being a fish owner all of
a sudden and i keep telling her that
actually it's called fish keeping
according to all the videos i've watched
about it and she says wait you're
watching videos about people who own
fish
and i say they're fish keepers and yes
and around around we go
a man becomes bizarrely fixated on some
arbitrary thing
a woman looks on confused
and it's the great dance of life
then we get to the biggest problem that
i noticed in this story
needless to say i noticed no problems
with a man who simply wants nothing but
to dig
all of the problems as usual are with
the woman
especially when she acknowledges that
the man is happy when he digs he's
fulfilled he's doing what he wants to do
what he's called to do and yet she
talked to her friend and decided that
though he's happy and seemingly mentally
well adjusted he must be crazy women
listen
i know i'm not gonna stop you from
talking to your friends
but just realize that if you who spend
every day with your man still struggle
and understand all of his ways
then what chance does your friend have
what insight can she really offer about
him what does she know
is she even in a healthy relationship
herself
has she even seen the tunnel
or is she making judgments about the
tunnel without all the facts
a tale is all this time
the meddling friend
this is the scourge of men everywhere
so
just stop that ladies let the man be let
him be a man let him dig
let him get his 18 000
aquarium yes it's 18 000
but it's worth the investment
and it helps with equity in your home or
something maybe
anyway let him live damn it that's all
i'm saying otherwise
you're canceled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. florida ends tax breaks for disney
gen saki cries at the prospect of not
transiting the kids literally cries and
elon musk sets the stage for the next
phase of his crusade to take over
twitter check it out on the michael
knowles show